President Obama has done some positive
things with regard to the war on drugs
he directed federal agencies not to try
to supersede state legalization and
decriminalization of marijuana for
example he released some nonviolent drug
offenders for prison he was president
during a time when many states legalized
and further continued to decriminalize
marijuana but what does President Obama
really think about the broader
legalization of marijuana well just days
before leaving office I think under 50
days at this point President Obama said
that he believes marijuana should be
treated like wait for it
cigarettes or alcohol legal regulated
and taxed he did what's being called an
exit interview with Rolling Stone
magazine and he said that yes we should
be treating marijuana as a public health
issue the way we do with tobacco the way
we do with alcohol making clear that the
patchwork of state and federal laws are
completely untenable here is what he
told a Rolling Stone look I've been very
clear about my belief that we should try
to discourage substance abuse and I am
NOT somebody who believes that
legalization is a panacea but I do
believe that treating this as a public
health issue the same way we do with
cigarettes or alcohol is the much
smarter way to deal with it
now if you've paid attention to what
President Obama has said over the years
this is not hugely surprising or without
precedent back in 2014 he said to The
New Yorker in an interview New Yorker
magazine uh that marijuana was less
dangerous than alcohol quote in terms of
its impact on the individual consumer
more recently he told TV host Bill Maher
I think we're going to have a more
serious conversation about how we are
treating marijuana and our drug laws
generally now in contrast Donald Trump
who uh thinks the president can just do
whatever he wants when he is the
president and it becomes the law
President Obama understands and
reiterated that changing federal
marijuana laws is not something the
president can just do and he's referring
to the DEA which
recently turned down a petition to
lessen the federal restrictions on
marijuana to reschedule marijuana which
absolutely should have been done and
President Obama understands you can't
just fix it all as the president and
advocates of legalization are really
angry because he now has implied
previously many times that he's for
legalization now days before leaving
office he says it should be like
cigarettes and alcohol and the advocates
of legalization are saying if he had
done this in its third month as
president we would be in a completely
different situation right now because
just the opinion of the president does
really matter the counterpoint to that
would be had he done that on month three
of his presidency
it could have significantly impacted
other aspects of policy that he would
try to dictate in the future I mean the
president's position on policy does
matter even though if he may not be able
to enforce it directly yet but it kinda
reminds me of his position on same-sex
marriage how it evolved only when the
majority of Americans supported it as
well yes just for political expediency
the good thing is he evolved on that
early enough that we ended up seeing it
at least partially push forward national
legal same-sex marriage and the the
broader issue here is there is the fear
that 99% of what President Obama has
done is about to be undone by the donald
trump administration remember that the
guy who's coming in to be the next
Attorney General jeff Sessions said good
people do not smoke pot and that he used
to like the KKK until he found out that
they smoked pot we're about to go in a
very different direction here that is
absolutely for sure yeah I think Obama's
happiness to my on issues like this will
go to the fact that he's going to go
down as maybe a mediocre president or
slightly better than average because he
wasn't a champion for for things like
this you think so I think history will
judge President Obama kindly I really do
and I know that as progressives there
are many areas where we flat-out
disagree with him and think he did the
wrong thing or not enough of the right
thing but if you sort of adjust for what
can presidents do particularly when you
consider Republican obstructionism think
about what has been achieved by
President Obama it's a bigger can of
worms that were opening level is wrong I
I don't I think history will judge
President Obama kindly I know the
trumpets and the alt writers don't but
an issue that we will
talk about in the future